second move here it is there's a little  bump right  right there right there is what they  call it that's enough  right but he's two and he started to say  where the blow takes place and there you  see the reaction he can't believe it  where the blow takes place is of utmost  importance  the head and neck region are frowned  upon in the region that duncan struck  obviously is also frowned upon and he is  gone luca dunches has been ejected with  a  flagrant two foul wow  so again remember that originally was a  review purely to see if the  foul occurred before the shot clock hit  zero and then when they reviewed it they  saw  wait a second luca took a shot at colin  that was not approved of and he will  take a  slow walk back at the mavericks dressing  room as luka dodge  this night is over  so sexton will shoot two free